Speaker 1: OK, I want to start today with
how to research a news story that you read
on the internet.
I often talk about media literacy, critical
thinking, epistemology, understanding why
we believe the things we believe.
And part of this as news consumers is, is
what I'm reading trustworthy.
You can, I believe what I'm reading.
So I'm going to do this in kind of order of
depth and time.
So like, this is the order you could do it
in and you could stop at any time.
This is this is going to be a lot of work
is the truth, and it's not realistic that
every news consumer is going to do this level
of research on every single story.
But the typical thing that happens is we have
an article, the article says something and
we need to figure out, can can we trust it?
And this is to be very clear, not how you
would do academic research.
I know some people will say, David, this is
not how academics research academic topics.
No, no, no.
I'm just saying this is something the average
news consumer can do.
If you want to at least have a framework for
figuring out, can I believe what I'm reading?
So I deliberately picked an article from the
website Raw Story to start with.
I'm not criticizing Raw Story.
I'm just using Raw Story because it's an article
that is emblematic of so much of what there
is on the internet, which is it's basically
a rewrite.
It's not a primary source.
This is an article based on another article.
OK, so let's start here and we'll go and you.
You could stop anywhere, but this is the order.
I'd suggest you're presented with an article.
The article is from Raw Story, and it says
New York Lieutenant Governor Brian Benjamin
arrested on federal bribery charges.
OK, now you start reading through the article
and you will realize, Oh, this is not original
reporting.
This is a rewrite of an original article.
In this case, it's really easy to tell because
the first line is.
The New York Times reported that New York
Lieutenant Governor Brian Benjamin has surrendered
to federal authorities on bribery charges.
Now you can finish reading this article if
you want, or you could go right to the primary
source.
So we go to the primary source, which is the
New York Times article.
Great.
So you can read this article.
This would be the next thing to do.
Lieutenant Governor Benjamin resigns following
campaign finance indictment.
Brian Benjamin, New York's second in command
to the governor, was charged with bribery.
OK, so you read this article?
Great.
Now one thing that is useful to do in assessing
media bias would be, well, this is a New York
Times article.
What's the deal with The New York Times?
We all sort of know The New York Times, but
imagine that it's a less well-known primary
source.
But the the next thing that you would do is
you would Google the name of the media outlet
and the word bias or the word source watch.
If there's a source watch page that can be
useful and you will find websites that will
assess the credibility of the source.
In the case of the New York Times, there's
many all sides dot com.
We'll talk to you about the New York Times,
and it says the New York Times leans left,
and it gives you information about how that
was determined, and it tells you different
things about the New York Times.
The ad fund has media page will have a page
about the New York Times bias and reliability
source watch for some more prominent media
outlets will tell you about what is The New
York Times?
Again, New York Times.
Most of us don't need to do this, but you
might come across a source and you don't know
if it's credible, so you would want to after
finding the primary source.
Learn a little bit about the media outlet.
Great.
Now sometimes it's about the author of the
article.
The author themselves might be notable.
In this case, it's a group of authors from
the New York Times William Ramsbottom, Nicholas
Van Doce and Jeffrey Mayes.
If Bob Woodward is the author, the author
has a multi-decade history, and you can examine
that to kind of build your assessment of the
of the story.
These are less well-known authors.
And so just as an example.
William Rasch bomb is not notable enough to
have his own wiki page, but you can at least
look at the William Rash Bomb page on the
New York Times, and it tells you this is a
senior writer, metro staff.
He does political and municipal corruption.
So OK, this is not like a culture writer writing
about political corruption.
It's a political corruption story, and that's
what this particular journalist writes about.
He used to cover federal courts in Brooklyn.
He was the newspaper's police bureau chief.
Great.
OK.
So we have a bunch of information about William
Rash Bomb, and he seems well-suited based
on his experience to write about this type
of thing.
Great.
OK, so we could stop here and we could say,
like, this is it?
This is a it's an author who knows about this
topic in a generally reliable media outlet.
We're comfortable.
OK, now you could go further.
This is an article about federal bribery.
So you could actually say, Well, let me look
at the underlying law, and Cornell has a great
website where you can look up any law and
statute and you can say, let me learn what
is in the bribery of public officials and
witnesses.
Federal statute, because that's what this
entire story is based on.
Great.
Well, I might also want to know the history
of such charges.
Who else has been charged with federal bribery?
Who's been convicted?
Is there a political nature to these types
of charges?
So there is a wiki page called List of United
States Officials.
The list of United States state officials
convicted of federal corruption charges, which
includes bribery.
Now you might say well, but David, Wikipedia
is not a good source.
Wikipedia is a great aggregation when there
are citations because you can start looking
through this list and you see all these different
people.
Governor Rod Blagojevich and many others and
their citations for all of these, you can
actually look at notes.
And if you say, Oh, OK, well, what was the
deal with Rod Blagojevich's conviction?
So it's actually very, very useful for that.
And then also, you know, it could be useful
again, diving deeper to look at information
about the person that the article is about.
This entire story is about the lieutenant
governor, Brian Benjamin.
So you might start with their wiki page.
And again, you're not using Wiki so much as
a source.
You're using it as a kind of clearinghouse
for citations, and you could learn about Brian
Benjamin's history.
Does he have a history of legal trouble?
On and on.
OK, so so you would go from there?
You could find kind of key information about
the person in their bio.
That's not in the article.
So this is like the minimum to really more
deeply start understanding a topic and knowing
whether remember, we started with a rewrite
on Raw Story and compare what you would know
just reading the Raw Story article versus
actually doing this work now.
This is just a frame.
Imagine it's a science story.
Well, that's arguably more complex, imagine
that we're looking at an article about anti-nuclear
activists are warning about building new nuclear,
well, OK, that's a lot.
So is it the original source or not?
We would want to go to the primary source,
but nuclear power is a major academic topic,
so we might even go to scholars google.com
and search for nuclear power.
Nuclear safety differences between 40 year
old nuclear power and modern nuclear power.
OK, so so it takes work.
And understandably, most people don't have
time to do this level of investigation.
For every news story you get.
But it should at least let you know that reading
a piece on Raw Story is not going to leave
you informed in a way that I would like to
be if I'm going to be talking about a topic.
Keep in mind when the anti-vaxxers say, I've
done my research, think about what research
they may have done, and you can actually use
this framework to inquire and probe whether
they've really actually done their research.
So hopefully this is useful.
Let me know.
Maybe at some point I'll do another example.
You know, I deliberately picked a pretty cut
and dry story which just like a guy, got arrested.
And here's here's why.
To show the depth you can go in.
Even for that, if this is useful, I'm glad
to glad to do it again with other topics